The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Let's talk
about the V-Model, here.
We are-- interesting, we have
a little bit of a lag here.
So the lifecycle management
is our last topic for today
and that sort of
completes the V. And then
next [AUDIO OUT] manufacturing.
So what I'd like to cover
today is essentially
a definition of
[INAUDIBLE] mean by that,
and then focus on the lifecycle
[INAUDIBLE] also known
as the [? ilities. ?]
Discuss a little bit
where they come from, how
much we know about them.
The bulk of the
discussion is going
to be a case study
called Reconfiguration
of Communication
Satellite Constellations.
And this sort of explains
the idea that system,
once you brought a system
into operation, that's
not the end of the story.
The system is going to continue
to live and change and be
modified over its life.
I'll try to summarize
some of the key concepts
over the whole semester.
And then I have one
slide on career and study
recommendations, if
you want to go further
into systems engineering.
So lifecycle management.
So this is my definition of
what lifecycle management is.
It's essentially the active
engagement of-- it's the active
engagement of all the
stakeholders with the system,
between the time when
it starts to operate--
so you've done
the commissioning,
you've done the operations--
until you decide to decommission
and retire the system.
So it's during the
whole operation life.
And what you want
to do, is you want
to maximize the
value that you gain
from the system's existence.
And so life cycle
management starts
from the very, very, very start.
And so I listed
here some activities
that are included in
lifecycle management.
So obviously daily operations,
you know monitoring,
is the system
working as expected?
Training and certification
of the operators.
Sometimes, you know,
in long live systems,
the people who were the early
operators, generation one,
are not necessarily the
people who are going
to operate for the whole life.
So you have to have
new people operate.
Maybe one of the most
extreme examples of that
is an airplane
known as the b-52.
Have you heard of this?
This airplane might be the
first plane that actually has
a 100 year operational life.
And there are apparently Navy--
Air Force guys at MIT,
you can confirm this,
that there's actually like--
the grandfather was
the first generation
and there's like third
generation pilots now flying
on the b-52.
That's what I've been told.
Did you hear this as well?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, That's correct.
PROFESSOR: Do some
of these people?
AUDIENCE: No, I've
never actually worked
on that airframe.
PROFESSOR: OK.
But anyway, so
that's what I mean
by [INAUDIBLE] not just
the initial operators,
but over multiple generations.
Then the third thing
here is servicing.
And servicing comes
in two flavors,
of preventive
maintenance, you know
regular maintenance, and
then corrective maintenance,
which we also call repair.
Dealing with small and large
failures, recalls, anomalies.
This is a big deal in
the automotive industry,
as we know.
Increasingly
protecting the system
from either random
or targeted attacks.
Cyber, physical, right,
physical security but also cyber
security is becoming
a huge topic.
Sharing and archiving
the data that's
being produced by the system.
More and more systems produce
larger amounts of data.
Well, what do you do with it?
How do you store that data?
Upgrading and retrofitting
the system as needed.
So retrofitting means
we're physically
changing the configuration
of the system--
right?-- over its life
to add new capabilities.
And upgrading; upgrading
can be done sometimes
without having to
change the hardware.
So you're doing a software
upgrade, or software update,
software patching.
All of this would
go under upgrades.
Cross strapping the
system with other system
in a federation of systems.
So what I mean by
this is a system
may have been designed
just to operate on its own,
but now you're connecting
it with another system.
This happened, for example,
the electrical grid.
Right?
The early electrical grids were
local, regional power grids.
And now we've connected
them, in the US
we have three major grids, the
eastern, the western, and then
Texas has its own grid.
Texas does a lot
of its own stuff.
It's called ERCCOT.
And then here in
Europe, you know
the European electrical grid
is now continental-wide.
It didn't used to be.
And of course, that has big
implications for operations.
Reducing the
resource consumption
and environmental burden
of the system over time,
and then finally,
decommissioning
the system when
it's time to do so.
And in many systems,
this is a big challenge
as to finding when
is the right time
to decommission the system.
And that's often the
case when, you know,
the operating costs exceed the
value that the system delivers.
So this is a pretty
long list here.
And a lot of tasks, a lot
of decisions to be made.
Any questions about this list?
I don't think it's
complete, but this
is a lot of things you need to
take care of during operations.
Here's a more
graphical view of this.
So this is my sketch of the
systems engineering lifecycle.
So this is part one, right?
Conceptual design-- conception,
design, and implementation.
You start the lifecycle, you
do something like a system
requirements review, understand
the mission, the requirements,
the constraints.
You do conceptual design,
that's where you do creativity,
architecting, trade studies.
As a PDR, you choose--
so in this case, you
know, we're going
to go through this
triangle concept
and then you design all
the details within it.
That's where we do modeling,
simulation, experiments, MDO.
And we iterate--
sometimes you have
to iterate this
[? dashed ?] duration means
abandoning the concept you chose
and go for a different concept.
That's usually undesirable.
After the CDR, we
implement the system,
we turn information to
matter, and this all
happens in a technological,
economic, social context.
So then, the second part of
it, which in many systems--
if this is 10 years, this
could be 30 years or more--
is the actual operational space.
So the system has now been
tested, validated, verified,
and deployed.
And now, you know, we
operate the system.
Things break, we need to service
it, and then I have this--
you see, there's two
versions of the system.
One is solid, and the
other one is kind of faint.
That's the virtual
version of the system.
So one of the big concepts
that's being pushed now,
certainly in the US by the
DOD, but also other places.
Is the idea of a digital twin.
The idea of a digital
twin is that there's
a physical system--
right?-- that exists,
and then there's
a digital version, a
digital twin of that system,
somewhere on a computer
that mirrors exactly
what the real system is doing.
So if something breaks
on the physical system,
well that same component
fails in the digital twin.
And then, before you actually
do a repair or any actions,
you execute those actions
on the digital twin
to see whether the system
will operate properly.
And so this is kind of
the latest thinking,
is that for any system we
should have a digital twin doing
operations.
Upgrading the system.
So in this case, we're
adding things to it,
we're connecting it.
You know, and then at some
point, the system does degrade.
Because, for example,
you know, materials, age,
they get brittle.
Technology becomes obsolete.
You know, it gets harder and
harder to maintain spare parts
or the suppliers of the
original spare parts
went out of business.
So these really
old legacy systems
can be very
expensive to operate.
And then at some
point you liquidate
and it's the end
of the life cycle.
So I've already told you
about one example of this,
which is the space shuttle.
And so I'm not going
to belabor this again,
but I think it's a great
opportunity to learn.
The space shuttle had a 10 year
design life, roughly from 1971
until '81, first flight.
And then we operated
the shuttle for 30 years
and we had a total of 135
launches during that time.
We spent $192 billion dollars
on the shuttle program.
And if you average
that, it's $1.5 billion
per flight, which is a
lot more than was planned.
But just yesterday
here at the EPFL,
we had the annual meeting
of the Swiss Space Center.
And one of the astronauts
here, Claude Niccolier
and his colleague,
Professor [? Mehron ?]
gave a great talk
about the Hubble
and the servicing of the Hubble
and the amazing things we've
learned through it.
And you guys at
MIT, Jeff Hoffman,
was part of at least the first
servicing mission as well.
So there's incredible things
that were done by the shuttle.
And so I think we need to
acknowledge that, not just
the fact that it
was very expensive.
It accomplished great
things during its life.
But you know, if we had a chance
to do it again, would we--
would we come up with
the exact same system,
would we make all the
same design decisions?
You know, we lost two of them.
Probably not, we could probably
do something-- something
different.
So here's what we wanted,
and then finally, we
got a much more complex
system in the end.
And particularly my sense is
that a lot of the things that
made the shuttle expensive
to operate during its life
were things related
to maintainability.
Right?
Reliability and so forth.
So the lifecycle
properties, which I
want to talk about next.
So I'm just going to
repeat the questions,
so you guys can hear as well.
So the question was
about reusability.
So the shuttle was--
the orbiter was fully reusable.
The external fuel
tank was not reusable.
Right?
And then the solid
rocket boosters
were partially
reusable because they
had to be stripped
down, you know,
and rebuilt, essentially,
for every launch.
The idea of Blue Origin
and then Space-X Stage One,
flying it back to
the launch site,
is absolutely the fact that
if you can make it reusable,
then you can amortize
the capex in that element
over multiple flights.
And it should drop,
you know, the cost
by a factor of
five or 10 or more.
Now, the devil's in
the details, right?
So if you start and restart
an engine multiple times,
you can have a big
transient every time.
So was this system,
in fact, designed
to withstand these transients?
Can it handle multiple starts?
What does it do
to the materials?
And so forth.
And so to really model
this ahead of time,
and then test it over
the cycles is the key.
So in the shuttle, the
big problems-- the two
major subsystems in the
shuttle, in the orbiter,
in particular that
made it expensive
and the difference
between the top picture
and the bottom picture was a,
the TPS, the thermal protection
system.
You know, every tile has
hit a different curvature
in geometry, so really
inspecting every tile,
replacing tiles, making
sure that the TPS--
because just one
weakness in the TPS
could basically be
fatal on re-entry.
And so, TPS was
very difficult and--
you know, as opposed to
an ablative heat shield
that you just sacrifice
the heat shield completely.
And then the other
was the main engine--
the shuttle main engine.
Originally, the idea was to
only do very deep inspections
and disassemble-- the
disassembly of the shuttle
main engine after the
first few test flights,
and then fly multiple times
without having to really
re-inspect or
disassemble the engine.
So they did the
disassembly of the engines
after the test flights
and then they just
kept doing it for every flight,
where the original intent was
to only do it for
the test flights.
And so the shuttle main engines
were the second big cost driver
in operations.
So re-usability is a great
idea, but to the degree
to which re-usability
actually happens
in reality, that's really
about detailed design decisions
you make.
OK.
So let me move on then.
When it comes to really
understanding lifecycle,
I do want to point you to
the 15288 standard, which
is the ISO 15288 standard,
which has a fairly complete list
of system lifecycle processes.
So this is, essentially
the system and software
engineering, system
lifecycle process standard,
that has a whole range of
processes that are described
in quite some detail.
And they're not just the
technical processes shown here
on the right side, we focused
a lot on those technical
processes in this class, the
stakeholders, the requirements,
the architectural design-- which
is essentially the conceptual
design--
but there's also the
project processes, right?
Executing the project
agreement processes.
So this would be
negotiating contracts,
you know supply contracts,
acquisition contracts, and then
all the organizational
things you
need to do to create the
right organization to execute
these projects.
So what's nice about
the 15288 standard
is that it's a pretty
broad standard.
OK.
So let me talk about the ilities
of the lifecycle properties
in particular.
What they are and how we
can describe them and how,
especially how they
relate to each other.
And so the paper
that underlie this
lecture that you need
to get some more detail.
And this is one of them.
So this paper is called
Investigating the Relationships
and Semantic Sets Among
Lifecycle Properties.
And we published this about
three years ago in Delft
at the CESUN Conference.
So the background on
here is the following,
is that as you've seen,
complex engineering systems
live for decades--
some of them even
for centuries--
and the ilities--
by ilities, we mean
properties of systems that
are not the primary functional
properties.
In software engineering
they're often
called nonfunctional properties.
And the thing that's
tricky about the ilities
is that you often only can
observe them during operations.
So you know, you can test
systems in the short term,
you can see does it work?
Does it fulfill its function?
But whether certain
ilities are present,
it often only shows
itself over time.
And so most of the
research that's been done
and sort of quantifying
the ilities,
has been looking at these
properties one at a time.
So the questions we
wanted to go here,
wanted to answer is, which
of these lifecycle properties
are more prevalent than others?
You know, the top 20.
And then especially,
what's the relationship
among lifecycle properties?
Do they form what we
call semantic sets?
And then how could you
use this information?
And so here, we're
going to do this
using two different methods.
The first method is what I
call prevalence analysis.
We're going to look in the
literature and on the internet,
how frequently these
lifecycle properties show up,
are mentioned, how much
we know about them.
And then the second method
is a cognitive method.
Where we ask people to
give their understanding
of the lifecycle properties
and put them into a hierarchy,
and then we'll
compare the results.
So here are
essentially the results
from the prevalence analysis.
And this is ranked according to
the number of journal articles.
This is scientific
papers written,
where this particular key word,
by quality or reliability,
shows up in the title or in
the abstract of the paper.
And you can see this is
in units of thousands.
OK?
So quality is number one.
Right?
Quality is number one.
The most scientific papers
are written about quality.
And you can see, it's almost
a million journal articles.
This is-- I'll show
this to you over time,
but since 1884 is
the first year.
And the databases that we
use for this are called it's
Compendex and Inspect.
These are actually
combined-- if you
go to a website called
engineeringvillage.com,
this is sort of a master
database for scientific papers
and engineering.
That was the basis for this.
Number two, reliability.
Number three, safety.
Then flexibility,
robustness, and so forth.
And the other bar, the gray bar,
is if you Google essentially
for this particular keyword
and-- you know, keep in mind,
this was done about
five years ago--
this is the number--
the millions of hits
that you will get.
And, so you know,
there's a factor
of 1,000 difference here
between journal articles
and hits on internet.
But still, you can sort
of compare the two.
And so, in some
sense, the black bar
is the totality of
scientific knowledge
about this lifecycle property.
And then the gray bar would
be the amount of information
or uses--
usage of that knowledge,
at least as far
as it's represented
on the internet.
And what's interesting
is, in some cases
the black bar is smaller
than the gray bar, which
means that common
usage is [? leading. ?]
So sustainability
would be an example.
Everybody talks
about sustainability,
companies have--
they say, our system is
sustainable because, you know,
it uses less resources, it
produces less emissions.
But the actual amount
of scientific knowledge,
the actual amount of
research as to what
really is sustainability and
how do you design for it,
is actually smaller
than the usage.
And then there's areas
where it's the opposite.
Like for example, modularity.
Right?
You see that in modularity.
So in the relative sense,
academic interest is leading.
We see there's quite a lot
of literature on modularity.
In mathematics, you know,
modularity and software,
modularity and design,
but most people--
you know, modularity per
se is not so interesting
and so exciting to
the general public.
So keep in mind that
for some ilities,
there's an imbalance
essentially,
between our understanding of--
the scientific knowledge,
our understanding
to be design, how to design
for it, and you know,
how frequently at least
a keyword is used.
Now here, this is
a little bit more--
this is a little
bit harder to see.
This is essentially looking
at these lifecycle properties
over time.
So what this graph
those you know
is starting here in 1884,
cumulatively the number
of journal articles published
about each lifecycle property.
And roughly what way
you can think about this
is that there's some lifecycle
property, the top four--
five that we've been actually
working on for a long time.
Even safety, you know, there's
some interesting articles
in the 1890s about safety
for example, in mines.
You know, coal mines.
There's an article
about how does
the impact of lighting--
better lighting-- on safety
and productivity in 1890.
And so they show that just
providing better lighting,
actually has a dual
benefit; fewer accidents,
fewer fatalities, and
better production output.
And so that's-- and this was a
scientific study that was done
by comparing data in different
mines and actually performing
some experiments.
Then you have a group
of life cycle properties
that we only started really
thinking about and publishing
about I would say,
around World War Two.
Such as usability,
maintainability,
and my interpretation of
this is that especially
during World War Two, a big
difference made logistics.
How easy was it was it
to use different weapons?
How easy was it to
maintain equipment?
It became a huge
determining factor
in the outcome of the war.
You know, for example, in North
Africa in the North African
theater, you know tanks, trucks
being exposed to the sand
and so forth.
So people really
started thinking
about the military,
started thinking heavily
about the importance
of maintainability
in the design of these systems.
And after the war then, a lot
of these concepts like usability
and maintainability
started spreading
into general civilian life
and products and so forth.
The third type of ilities
are the newer ones
that we've done research
on just since the 70s,
in the last 30 years.
So here in this category
I would put things
like sustainability,
recyclability, evolvability,
even interoperability-- which
means the ability of systems
to connect together and work
across system boundaries.
Those are pretty recent
lifecycle properties
and we're still actively
researching them.
So another way to show this is
by essentially making a network
of these lifecycle properties.
And so the way-- this is still
all using this prevalence data.
Essentially what you see
here is a network diagram
that has these lifecycle
properties in a network
relationship.
Let me just explain, so
the size of the nodes
relates to how much
knowledge we have.
Essentially the height of
the bars that we saw earlier.
And then the strength
the thickness of the line
relates to the
strength of-- really
how closely are these
two ilities related.
And the way this
is calculated it
is using the so-called
2-tuple correlation.
So you take, essentially,
articles that have--
you look at articles that
have, for example reliability
and maintainability
in the same article.
Right?
And then you divide
that by the total number
of articles on reliability
and or maintainability.
And that's a ratio
between 0 and 1.
And then this graph was produced
with a cutoff strength of so.
1, right?
So if there's more
than 10% of articles
list these two
properties together,
then there will be a line here.
And the stronger the line,
the thicker the line is,
the more closely, the
more often these concepts
are mentioned in
the same article
or the same piece of work.
So that reflects the
strength of relationship.
Now, what's interesting is
when you first look at this,
you don't see much.
But after you look
at this for a while,
you start to realize
a few things.
First of all, in the
center of the graph
we have the classic
ilities of engineering.
Quality, safety, reliability,
and I would argue flexibility
as well.
Those are the top four
that we saw before.
And then around the
periphery of the graph,
we have lifecycle properties
that are more recent.
We haven't really thought
about them too much,
we don't fully know how
to design for them yet.
And if you look
at them in groups,
I will argue that there are
three major groups here.
So the first group
in the upper left
is things like maintainability,
durability, reliability,
quality, and so forth.
So this is all about,
is the system made well,
with high quality,
particularly early in its life.
Right?
Then we have a group here on
the right, and this is about,
is the system easy to change.
Is it easy to change the system
configuration-- flexibility,
extensibility, modularity and
scalability, interoperability.
Those are all different
sub-flavors, if you want,
of being able to modify
the system over its life.
And so that's a group of
ilities that that goes together.
And then the third one is
resilience, robustness,
quality, safety.
And so this is really
related to performance
of the system under different
types of uncertainty.
You know, either
environmental variability
or failures in the system,
and the ability of the system
to withstand, or
at least perform--
you know, have good
residual performance
even in the face of failures.
So that's, I think, an
important way to think about it.
And when you're writing
requirements for systems--
like the system
should be resilient.
Then this helps
understand well, what
are the other properties
that are linked to it
and that maybe support that?
OK, any questions
here or at MIT about--
this is sort of method
one, is get data
about the lifecycle property
and put them in relation
to each other.
Any questions?
Johanna, any question there?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
So is this chart that you
have now actually used
in the initial design and
like conception [? con-ops ?]
to like try to tease out
the interdependencies,
or is it too abstract and just
more of an educational tool.
PROFESSOR: It's
really at this point--
you know this is fairly recent.
And this was just done
in the last few years.
So I don't think this has fully
penetrated system engineering
practice yet.
But the point-- the point that
I want to make here is that
there's a huge--
there's a huge gap right
now between when people
in briefings you know,
either at the Pentagon
or at a corporate
headquarters say,
you know we want a
sustainable product
or we want-- we're
a software company,
we do optical
networking and we want
we want to have the
most resilient design
of the industry.
You know, they'll put that
as a goal for the project.
The question then is,
well OK, that's fine.
But what does that really mean?
What does it really
mean, resilient?
You have to operationalize
that definition such
that you can derive from
it lower level requirements
that you can actually
go and design to,
that you can test for.
So what this helps you
to do is understand
what may be supporting--
what are supporting
elements that
will be related to resilience.
You know, what are supporting
concepts, supporting
lifecycle properties that
this property that you're
looking for is linked to?
Right?
So it's an evolution-- you
know, we know how to design now
for speed and energy
efficiency, and you know,
the sort of things that
were really hard to do 20,
30, 50 years ago.
It's pretty standard
practice now.
You know, how do you design
for optimal interoperability?
We don't quite know yet,
but we're finding our way.
And so what I believe
is that especially
the lifecycle properties on the
outer periphery of this chart,
those are the ones that
need more work and those are
the ones that we're really
learning how to operationalize.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, thanks.
That makes sense.
PROFESSOR: OK, good.
Let me talk about the
[? message ?] too.
So this was basically trying
to get to-- how do people,
how do humans--
there's semantics, semantics
means the meaning of words,
right?
Semantics is the science
of the meaning of words.
How do they interpret
these lifecycle properties?
And so humans have a
deep and possibly varied
understanding of the semantics
of these lifecycle properties.
So what was done here was
that a list of 15 life cycle
properties, many of them are
overlapping with the ones you
saw earlier, were presented
and then the challenge was to--
the question that
these four groups--
12 participants, four groups--
had to say, is there
a hierarchy here?
Are some higher level lifecycle
properties are some of them
lower level properties
that support these.
So there was a round one, find
the parent-child relationships,
describe these.
Interviews, and then
the second round.
So here's essentially what was
the results of the first round.
So four different
groups, so each of them
basically came up with its
own version of a hierarchy.
They didn't talk
to each other, they
were firewalled from each other.
And in all cases this
notion of value robustness
came out on top.
So value robustness means the
system should deliver value,
right, to the stakeholders.
Despite failures you know,
environmental changes,
so value delivery of the system
is the top, the most important
thing.
Then what's different here
is how do you achieve that?
So for example, you
see group one had
robustness and changeability.
So robustness
typically means even
if you don't make any changes to
the system, it should continue,
you know, it should
be survivable.
It should be versatile.
Changeable means
you actually modify
the system over its life.
And then we have lower level
properties like modularity
or reconfigurability.
And you know, there were
differences between the groups
but not as big as
you might think.
So in the second round, as a
result of the second round,
then this so-called means to
end hierarchy was constructed.
So means means, you know, these
are the enabling lifecycle
properties and ends means this
is the final, sort of this
is really what you
want to achieve.
And so this was
the result of that.
So again, at the top
we have this notion
of value robustness.
And this is achieved
by a combination
of survivability robustness
and changeability.
And then these, in turn,
are achieved by lower level
lifecycle properties.
And then at the
lowest level we have
things like
interoperability, modularity,
reconfigurability, and so forth.
And the difference
between the solid lines
and the dashed lines here
is that if it's a solid line
and these are
directed arrows, that
means that three or four
out of four groups, right?
So the majority
of groups had this
is a particular
parent-child relationship.
And if it's a dashed line it
means only two out of four.
And if it's only one out
of 4, it's not shown here.
OK?
So this is kind of a combined
result across the four groups.
So you know, what can
we take from this?
So first of all,
lifecycle properties
are absolutely critical.
You'll find us in
mission statements,
you know, you'll find it
in even in advertising.
Right?
A lot of companies say we have
we have a robust solution,
we have a sustainable system,
we have resilient networks.
So it really is a huge,
huge selling point.
It's very critical.
What I encourage you to
do as system engineers is
take a critical look at this
and say, well how resilient
is resilient?
You know, how many subsequent
failures of the system
can you tolerate?
Sustainability;
what does that mean
in terms of kilowatt
hours per hour of usage?
You have to get
down to the details
to start quantifying what
these lifecycle properties mean
and compare them among systems.
Despite differences, the two
methods that we just looked
at-- so one is the prevalence
analysis and the other one is
the human semantic exercise--
despite differences, the high
level conclusions were similar.
So some ilities are closely
related to each other and form
semantic sets, meaning
they're tied together by both
[? synonymie ?] or
polysemi relationships.
[? Synonymie ?] means they
essentially mean the same--
they're synonymous-- they
essentially mean the same
thing.
polysemi means-- it
is one word, but it
means you can have
possible sub meanings.
Right?
So the idea of groups
of semantic sets.
And those groups
essentially are robustness--
so this is the
ability of the system
to perform its job despite
either internal or exogenous
disturbances.
Right?
That's robustness.
Flexible or changeable,
which means that you
can modify the system easily.
You know, if you operate
the system for a while
and then you realize,
Ah, I need the system
to do something else.
Or I need to adapt it, or make
it bigger, or make it smaller,
or add some function.
So you would modify
the system and that's
flexibility or changeability.
And then resilient
and survivable
is very specifically the
ability of this system
to continue performing
despite failures or attacks.
Right?
That's what resilience
really means.
And so those seem to be the big
three semantic clusters that we
see in life cycle properties.
And then the third
point here is there
appears to be a hierarchy of
life cycle properties with two
or three levels.
Where we have the lower
level properties of systems
like modularity, for example.
Really your customer
probably does not
care about modularity, right?
If you advertise the
modularity of the product, some
of the more educated, some
of the more technically
savvy customers, they may
understand what that means.
But most of your
customers really
won't appreciate
modularity because it's
kind of a low level
form-oriented technical
property of the system.
But what they will appreciate
is the ability of the system
to be reconfigured or
adaptive for different pieces,
so interoperability,
modularity, et cetera
are low level
lifecycle properties
that act as enablers of a higher
level lifecycle properties.
And so future work--
future work in this
area is to both just
to apply these methods
to a broader set
abilities, larger group of
test subjects and more data,
but also from a
practical standpoint
to operationalize better.
How do we write requirements?
How do we actually design
for the lifecycle properties
like resilience,
flexibility, changeability.
How do you really design it?
So go from the keyword
to real engineering
by operationalizing the
sub-attributes or factors
in the system.
OK?
So that's a quick
summary of life--
you know, I could go on
for hours about this.
I'm very passionate
about this topic
and I will say that
people who have
dealt with large complex
systems you know, whether you're
operating the transportation
system of a city
or in airline
operations, or you're
running the IP infrastructure
of a major corporation.
These words, these
words are real.
These words are you know,
real dollars, real challenges.
This is really
where the action is
in a lot of these
large complex systems.
OK.
Any comments or questions
about lifecycle properties?
What they are, how they
relate to each other,
why they're important.
Voelker, did you want
to maybe say something?
OK.
All right.
So let me talk about--
try to make this a
little more real.
Let me talk about a case
study, a very specific case
study about communications
satellite constellations.
And this is the second paper
that underlies today's lecture.
And so let me give you a
little context for this first.
So this work here was originally
published about a decade ago,
in March 2004.
And that was a few years after
the Iridium and Globalstar--
these the two well known
communication satellite
constellations--
had been launched.
And I have to give you a
little context, when I first
came to MIT in the
mid 1990s, there
was a huge interest in this area
of satellite constellations.
You know commercially,
scientifically, in fact,
the impression was there were so
many applications for satellite
compilations filed,
that we're going
to have so many satellites
up there you won't even
see the sun anymore.
It was just like thousands
and thousands of satellites.
And the Iridium and
Globalstar were really
the first two constellations
that were fully
developed, launched,
and both of them
failed commercially
within a very short time,
a couple of years.
And so after this happened
the whole market and interest
in satellite constellations
collapsed for a long time,
until about two years ago,
two or three years ago.
Now people talk about
these constellations again.
You know, constellations of
[INAUDIBLE],, Iridium Next.
You know, there's sort
of new enthusiasm ,
new wave of enthusiasm
for constellations.
So this paper, and this case
that I want to tell you about
is really about the first wave.
And in terms of the
ilities, the one
that that I'd like to
explain to you about here
is flexibility and scalability.
Rather than thinking about
a system as something
that you design and
build all at once,
how do you design a system
such that you can gradually
deploy it?
We call that staged
deployment approach.
And what's the benefit of that?
So here's some pictures
you see on the right side,
this is what the original
iridium satellites look like.
They actually use
phased array antennas--
and actually both use
phased array antennas.
So you have individual
elements here.
And by differentially
phasing the signal,
you can actually steer the beam.
This was a very new
technology at time.
And then the
Globalstar satellite
shown at the lower picture.
Here is a little
bit of that data.
So both of these were
launched in the late 1990s.
Iridium has 66
satellites, Globalstar 48.
Iridium is a polar
constellation,
so the satellites go almost
directly over the poles.
Globalstar is a walker
constellation, so inclined.
Doesn't quite give you
full global coverage,
it's about plus or
minus [? 78 ?] degrees,
so you can't use
Globalstar at the poles.
The altitudes are a
bit different too.
Iridium is at 780 kilometers,
while Globalstar is at 1,400.
Which-- I know at least one
or two of you are working
on the Van Allen--
the Van Allen Belt Commission.
Right? [? The cube stats ?] to
measure the Van Allen Belts.
Somebody mentioned that
today, who was that?
No?
Did I hear that wrong?
It was mentioned, right?
So who was that?
Arnold, and he's not here.
Ah, see.
So 1,400 kilometers, are
you actually pushing,
you're starting to push the
lower edges of the Van Allen
Belt. So one of the big,
you know, in some sense,
it's easier to be higher because
you need fewer satellites
to cover the whole earth.
But the higher you
go, the more exposed
you are to the
radiation environment.
You get closer to
the Van Allen Belt,
so that's the big
trade-off there.
You know, the mass
of the satellites,
they're between 450 and 700
kilograms, transmitter power,
around 400 watts.
You know, which is not that
much, if you think about it,
right?
That's four very strong
light bulbs, the old style
light bulbs.
And then what's very
different, again,
is the multi-access schemes.
So Iridium used time division
multiplexing and Globalstar,
which was supported by
Qualcomm, used essentially CDMA.
So you don't chop your frequency
band into separate channels,
you use the whole
frequency band and then
you use a pseudo
random access code
that essentially de-convolves
the signal for each channel.
The number of
channels, about 72,000,
about 120,000 duplex channels so
that you can actually-- duplex
mean you can carry on a two
way conversation as opposed
to just be asynchronous.
And then you can see the
data rates, quite low,
like per channel.
4.8 or kilobits per second,
2.4, 4.8, 9.6 for Globalstar
it's enough for
having a conversation.
And total system cost, Iridium
was about $5.7 billion dollars
and Globalstar
about $3.3 million.
Not including the cost
of the ground stations.
Both went bankrupt relatively
quickly after they launched.
However, they've been operating
really since then, right?
Since this time.
Iridium Next is currently
under development
and is scheduled
to launch in 2017.
Globalstar is publicly
traded and actually valued
as a company at $1.9
billion dollars.
So they're actually both--
you could almost
argue that they were
a decade ahead of their time.
And
I want to tell you a little bit
about the story of, especially
Iridium.
So here's a couple of press
releases, so things that
have been written in the press.
So look at this one,
26th of June, 1990.
Motorola unveiled
a new concept for
global personal
communication. [? Bases ?]
a constellation of low earth
orbit cellular satellites.
August 18th 1999, nine years
later, last week Iridium LLC
filed bankruptcy court
protection last investments
are estimated at $5 billion.
So the question is
why did it happen?
The technology actually
worked quite well, it
was not a technological failure,
it was a business failure--
but I would argue
a system's failure.
To think about the
problem differently,
so the fundamental challenge
is to properly size
the capacity of a large system.
So if you're
designing, you know,
a car factory, a
new power system
and for a future
uncertain demand,
it's very difficult to do this
because demand is uncertain.
So is it better to oversized the
system or are you conservative
and you make it smaller?
Market assumptions
can change, right?
In a seven to eight years.
So essentially the v, right?
Like getting back to the v.
Each of those two systems,
Iridium and Globalstar, it
took them essentially a decade,
almost 10 years-- right?--
to go across the whole v.
And when you make
your requirements,
your stakeholders, all the
stuff in the upper left portion
of the v, there's so many years
that elapse between when you
make those assumptions, you
write those requirements,
and when you actually go to
market a lot of things can
change.
And that's fundamentally
the challenge here.
Just to illustrate this
for you, showing some data,
this is cellular this
is not space space,
this is on the ground.
Cellular subscribers
for mobile phones.
I know this is hard
for your generation
to sort of understand
this, but we actually
didn't have mobile phones or
there were these clunky bricks
in your car.
You know, it's really
remarkable what happened.
So look at this
data, in 1991 which
is when the system was
just being developed,
there were less than 10 million
mobile phone users in the US.
It just wasn't-- it
was very expensive,
it was just not widely--
that technology hadn't been,
the networks weren't there.
You know, so the green bars
where the forecasts that was
done in 1991, as to how
quickly the mobile user
market would evolve in the US.
So their prediction was that
by 2000, a decade later,
there'd be just shy
of 40 million users.
OK?
Now the dark blue bar
is the actual evolution.
So actually by 2000 you know
the US now has 310 or so million
inhabitants.
So by 2000 there were
120 million users.
So the forecast that was
done 10 years earlier
was off by a factor of three.
That grounds, the
terrestrial mobile networks,
developed three times faster
than had been predicted.
Now that's great for the
terrestrial people, right?
AT&T and Comcast-- not
Comcast, Qualcomm, et cetera.
But the problem is, of course,
that because you know ground
based communications
was so much easier,
a lot of the market that
had been anticipated
for the satellite
based communications
was essentially eaten
away by this competitor,
by the ground based competitor.
VOELKER: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK.
Can you still hear it,
MIT, are you still with us?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Yes, you are.
OK.
Voelker wants to say something.
VOELKER: Actually, the figures
that you showed [INAUDIBLE]
and for once, Americans
did not look over the pond.
Because at that time in
Europe, the GSM systems
came really strong
and very quickly.
In the early 90s, you could
have already had your Sim card
in your cell phone [INAUDIBLE]
and in fact in America
then, you could only buy the
telephone with all the Sim card
in-- you had to buy
the whole system.
And so as the system
was controlled
by the large companies
and not by the users,
the large companies,
Motorola, thought
that they could
impose their satellite
system on the markets.
And in this case,
the country to the--
video recorders, hi fi
systems earlier, Europe
went much faster than America.
And actually
European GSM market--
cell phones, as you know them--
went much quicker.
And then Nokia, which
is actually European,
overtook and it took probably
the next decade for Americans
to catch up.
So finally here this was,
a combination of people
had the product and they
just couldn't get in the US.
So they were limited
to their own markets,
and not to sell their products
to the rest of the world
as they had done in the past.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, good point.
And in fact, you know
one of the things that--
I think both Globalstar
and Iridium had to do--
and this was a very
late decision, just
in the last couple of
years here before launch,
97, 98, is to make
their handsets dual use.
Like that if you
were in an area where
there was a cellular
network, the phone
would switch to that because
that would be cheaper,
and if you didn't
have cellular network
access it would automatically
try to communicate
to the satellite.
So there was a lot of--
there were a lot of
issues that came up
by essentially the markets, I
think in Europe, your point,
well for-- about the
GSM, and in the US just
developing quite differently
than had been anticipated.
OK so I want to give you
a little bit about sort
of economics.
In the end a lot of this is
driven by money, by economics.
And so this is
satellite economics 101.
The key question here
is how expensive is it--
what's the cost,
and then what is
the price that you can charge
for one minute of service,
right?
One minute, one unit of service.
And so look at
this equation here.
This is CPF, stands
for cost per function.
And so in the numerator we
have the lifecycle cost, which
is your initial investment.
And then we will
essentially capitalize
that with some interest rate k.
Plus then, for each
year of operation,
you have the operational costs
for that year you have to add.
So that's your initial--
that's your development costs,
your manufacturing costs
for the satellite,
including the launch costs.
And then the ops costs would be
operating your ground stations,
your networks, any
replenishment costs,
they would be in your ops costs.
And then you divide
this by what's
called here the number
of billable minutes.
That doesn't mean you're
actually going to bill people,
it means just they are
potentially billable minutes.
So that's the capacity
of the system,
[? see ?] the best times
you know, 365 days,
times 24 hours,
times 60 minutes,
times what's the load factor.
So the load factor
is essentially
the capacity utilization of
the system that you anticipate.
OK.
So that's the basic
equation for calculating
CPF, cost per function.
Plug-in some numbers here.
These are the numbers
that have been assumed,
you know a $3 billion
investment, 5%
interest rate, $300 million per
year of ops cost, 15 year life
cycle--
this is the capital
T, over 15 years.
100,000 channels--
that's your capacity.
Number of users in this
case, so the load factor
is simply the number of users
times the average activity
per user.
In this case, it seems to
be 1,200 minutes per year,
about 100 minutes per month.
OK?
So that gets you--
that gets you a CPF
of $0.20 per minute.
And based on that you
can-- the business case
was made based on
these kind of numbers.
And so 3 million users, just
3 million subscribers, right?
Not 3 million users
at the same time,
that number would
be much smaller.
That number can't be
bigger than 100,000
because that's your capacity.
So for example, if you run--
if you run a
fitness club, right?
At any given time
in your fitness club
you can have 50 or 100
people actually working out,
but your number of
customers, your subscribers,
should be 1,000 or 2,000.
And if they all show
up at the same time
you're in big trouble, right?
So that's the difference
between number of users
or the number of
subscribers and number
of active users
at any given time.
That's a big part of managing
these kind of systems.
However, what actually happened
is the number of actual users
grew much slower.
So if you plug-in some
different numbers,
let's keep all the
numbers the same,
except for the subscriber
base-- the number of users.
In this case we're going to
assume 50,000 users instead of
the three million.
This is closer to what
they had after about
a year of operation.
Now your CPF goes
to $12 per minute,
which is noncompetitive.
Right?
Except for some extremely, like,
military applications or making
some emergency phone
calls on an oil rig,
you know, on the ocean.
Most people at the time--
now and at that time--
would never pay that for
one minute of service.
And so that was the
fundamental problem,
is that the user base did not
materialize as fast as planned.
Therefore this cost per
function was way higher
and they did charge,
you know, $3 to $5
per minute of usage
of the system, which
as you try to squeeze
your existing users more,
you're not going to get the ramp
up and scale up in the system
that you need.
That was the fundamental
problem with the economics
of the system.
So let me talk a little bit
about the design decisions
the conceptual design of what
this design space looks like.
So fundamental-- oh, the other
thing I should mention to you,
what was interesting is after
the bankruptcy, both of Iridium
and Globalstar, both of the
chief engineers for both
of these systems
took refuge at MIT.
Essentially, they came to like--
Joel Schindall, who was the
chief engineer for Globalstar,
great guy, both very competent
people, came to MIT--
still there, still
a professor there.
And then Ray Leopold was
one of the three architects
for Iridium, also came
to MIT during the time.
So I had extensive
discussions with them,
and what you see
here on slide 25
is one result of
those discussions.
Which is, the key
design decisions
that they have to make,
fundamentally, there is--
you won't be
surprised to see this,
this is the magic
number seven, right?
Seven key design decisions.
When you design a satellite
consultation for communication
purposes, constellation type--
polar or walker,
orbital altitude,
minimum elevation angle
above the horizon--
that you can communicate--
satellite transmitting
power, the size
of your primary antenna,
your multi-access scheme.
So this is time division or
code division multiplexing.
And then the last one is about
the network architecture--
do you have inter-satellite
links, yes or no?
Inter-satellite links
means satellites
can talk to each other.
And Iridium chose that,
Globalstar did not.
So in Globalstar, the Globalstar
satellites cannot talk to each
other directly in space.
They can only talk--
it's a bent pipe system
to a ground station.
OK?
So if you this is like
the morphological matrix
that you learned about, you
just pick design decisions
in this morphological
matrix and you come up
with an architecture.
In fact, a full factorial
search of the space
would reveal 1,440 different
satellite architectures.
So that's on the input side,
what's the output vector?
What do you care about in
terms of output of the system?
Well first of all, performance.
So the performance-- this
is for voice communications.
In a sense it applies to
data communications as well.
It is your data rate
per channel, right?
4.8 Kbps, your bit
error rate, like
what is the average number
of bits that are wrong?
10 to the minus 3.
That's actually
pretty-- not a very--
that's not a very
stringent requirement.
And the reason is this is
for voice communication,
this is not for sending, you
know, commands to a spacecraft
going to Mars.
If you send commands, it would
have to be 10 to the minus 10,
or 10 to the minus 9.
Much, much better
bit error rate.
But this is OK for voice.
And then the link
fading margin, 16 DB.
This is the strength
of the signal, which
which will dictate
whether or not
you can use the phone under
trees or in buildings.
So you want this number to be
higher, but the higher it is,
you know given
the power you have
on the satellite, the
fewer channels you have.
So there's trade-offs.
So what was done here is to
keep the performance foxed,
and so that you can
compare architectures,
compare apples to apples.
Then we have capacity,
which is the number
of simultaneous duplex channels.
And then finally,
the lifecycle cost
of the system, which includes
research development, test,
and evaluation, satellite
construction and test, launch
and orbital insertion,
and then the operations
and replenishment.
So if the satellite
fails in orbit,
either you have to already
have prepositioned to spare,
or you're going to
launch a replacement.
And this actually
happened in both cases,
both constellations.
So in order to then, connect
the input to the output,
you need to build a simulator
or a model of this system.
And this is a high-level view
of what that model looks like.
So we take our input,
our design decisions,
and certain constants that we
assume-- a constant vector.
And cascade this information
from the constellation module,
takes the altitude and the
minimum elevation angle,
and produces--
t is the number of
satellites and p
is the number of
orbital planes, so this
is sort of orbital dynamics.
The spacecraft module
calculates the satellite mass,
the satellite network builds
essentially the communication
pathways.
The link budget will calculate
the capacity of the system.
You know, given those
performance constraints.
The launch module will
determine how many launches
do you need, from where.
And then the cost module
basically calculates
the total cost of the
system, the lifecycle cost,
and finally you get essentially
a trade-off of lifecycle cost
versus capacity of the system.
Let me just show you
some, you know, you say,
well that's tying together
a lot of information
into a multi-disciplinary model.
So what kind of
information do you have?
You have a mix, really
of physics based models--
so this is a very well known
equation, the eB/N0, that this
is the energy bit
over noise ratio.
This is a closed form
physics-based equation that
tells you how much
energy is there per bit--
what's the signal to noise
ratio on a per bit basis.
And this is a function of
transmitter power, receiver
and transmission gains,
various losses in the system.
And then some of the equations--
some of the information
is empirical.
For example, the relationship
between spacecraft
[? wet ?] mass
and payload power.
You know, if wanted to have
a closed form or you wanted
to have more detail, you
would have to almost build
a CAD model, right?
A separate model.
You'd have to-- for each
of the 1,440 architectures,
you'd have to manually construct
an individual detailed design.
And that's not feasible,
so what you do instead
is you use some prior
data-- and you can see here
a scaling relationship.
It's not perfect, but
we have error bars,
we know how good it is.
Satellite mass,
satellite wet mass
is a function of transmitter
power and, in this case,
propellant mass.
So two kinds of equations.
Benchmarking.
So once you have this model,
you need to ask the question,
how can I trust this model?
Does it give me a
reasonable answers?
And in this case,
benchmarking the process
of validating
simulation by comparing
the predictive response
against reality.
So just quickly here, showing
you four kinds of data.
So one is the simultaneous
channels of the constellation,
this is the prediction
of capacity.
You can see it's pretty good.
In this case, the model is
actually a little conservative.
So the blue bars are the
actual planned capacities.
The red ones or
magenta is simulated,
and you can see that the
simulation under-predicts,
slightly, the true
capacity of the system.
Life cycle costs, you saw that
Iridium was just a bit more
than $5 billion.
Globalstar was between $3
million and $4 million.
And so here we're in
the right ballpark.
And then in terms
of satellite mass
and the number of satellites
in the constellation required,
we matched that very closely.
And the reason for
this is, fundamentally
this is just geometry.
Right?
If I can tell you the altitude
and the minimum elevation
angle, and I'm telling you I
need I need global coverage
and I want dual redundancy,
so you can always
see at least two
satellites, it's
just geometry to be able to
figure out how many satellites
and how many orbital
planes you need.
And that's why the
model, or the simulation,
and reality match
very, very closely.
So this gives you
some confidence
that this model is reasonable.
So what you can
do with it is now
what we call Trade
Space exploration.
Which is, in a sense, what
you did for the [INAUDIBLE]
competition.
So this picture here, this
graph shows you the life cycle
costs over those
15 years, versus
global capacity of a system.
Each of these blue
dots represents one
of those 1,440 architectures.
And you can even see on
this, where Iridium actual
versus simulated falls and
where Globalstar actual
versus simulated falls.
So both of them were actually
off the Pareto frontier,
which was interesting and
led to quite some discussion.
And you can-- the
Pareto frontier itself
was, of course, very useful.
One of the reasons that Iridium
is not on the Pareto frontier
is that fundamentally, polar
constellations are inefficient.
And, if you think about
it, when the satellites are
crossing over the poles, they're
very close to each other.
And they're actually
not crossing
exactly over the poles, or you
could actually collide, right?
So you offset them slightly
to avoid collisions.
But some of the
satellites actually
get turned off when
they cross the poles.
So you're not utilizing your
assets super efficiently
in the polar constellation.
Which is one of the
reasons why they are not
on Pareto frontier.
Now, the way you would use
this in a traditional system
engineering approach, which is
traditional system engineering
approach means give
me the requirement,
write down the requirements,
and then find the minimum cost
design for that requirement.
So a requirement could be we
need a capacity of 50,000,
for example, and then you
find this intersection
with the Pareto
front, and that's
the minimum lifecycle
cost design that
gives you that capacity.
Right?
And that's the system
you pick, and that's
what you go and build.
And that's essentially
what they did.
The problem with this if
there is high uncertainty
is, the true requirement
is kind of unknown.
The market will tell
us in the future what
the true capacity should be.
So how do you deal with this?
Well, you could be--
we're going to be on
the safe side, right?
We're going to oversize--
so if the true demand,
the true capacity
that you would need,
is higher than
what you just had,
your system is going to
be under capacity, right?
Your system is going
to be undersized
for what it should be.
And so what happens in practice?
What do you think happens in
an under capacity situation?
What would you say?
The system is too small relative
to the market that you're in.
You're not capturing
as much as you can,
meaning a competitor
will probably capture.
I mean, I guess you can
change your price policy,
but fundamentally,
you're missing out
on market opportunity.
The other situation, which
is actually what happened,
is that the demand is much
less than we anticipated.
Your system is
oversized and remember,
once you launch a
satellite constellation,
it's not like a fleet
of taxis, right?
Where you just park
them in a parking lot.
You've already-- the
fixed cost is very high.
So if demand is below capacity,
you have all this investment
here, lifecycle cost has
been wasted because you
oversized the system.
And the challenge is
that the true requirement
is kind of like this-- there's
this probability, density
function.
Right?
It's a probabilistic
requirement, essentially.
And there's no set of
experiments because of all
the [INAUDIBLE] uncertainty.
It's not a systemic uncertainty.
There's no set of
experiments you
could do today that will help
you refine the requirements.
Now they did do market studies,
but again those market studies
were years ahead of when the
actual system was launched.
So they were unreliable,
fundamentally.
So what I'm arguing here
is in this kind of system
where you have
large uncertainties
as to the true requirements,
you shouldn't just
guess and then put billions
of dollars on a guess.
This is like playing
in the casino, right?
Essentially.
What you should do is think
about the problem differently.
And in this case, the
answer is staged deployment,
or one of the answers
is staged deployments.
So you build a system such
that it can adapt itself
to the uncertain demand.
So you build, initially,
a smaller, more affordable
system.
But-- and then the
system has already
built into it the
flexibility or scalability
to expand if needed.
But only if needed.
And there are two major
economic advantages to that.
One is that you don't need to
spend all the capital up front.
As so you're deferring
capital investment.
And you retain the decision
freedom to reconfigure or not,
and that's typically what
we call the real option.
You've created a real
option for the future.
So the question, then, is
well how valuable is that?
It is worthwhile doing this
staged deployment approach?
So there's probably
different ways of doing this,
and I just want to
share with you--
and this is from the
paper-- how this was done.
So step one is you partition
your design vector.
So you basically decide
which part of the system
is flexible-- because
you can't make everything
flexible typically--
what part is flexible
and what part is fixed, is
the base, you can't change it?
So in this case
usually the idea is
that the satellites
themselves, the design
of the satellite, the
transmitter power,
that their protocol, and
the network architecture
should be fixed, right?
Those things are
difficult to change.
We're going to allow the
astrodynamics, the actual shape
of the constellation,
to be flexible.
So keep the satellites
the same, only
change the arrangement in space.
So what you do is you
partition the design vector
into the flexible
and inflexible parts.
And when you do this,
in step two, what's
nice about this is you can
then actually find families
of designs, right?
You can find families
of designs where the--
we have a little lag here--
that you can find
families of design
that share the constant parts.
That have the common--
So what's shown in this
graph here-- this is again,
our design space, kind of
zoomed in a little bit more--
every one of these points that
are connected with these lines
uses the same types of
satellite [INAUDIBLE]..
Same transmitter power,
same antenna diameter,
and all of them have
inter-satellite links.
So effectively,
you're partitioning
the design say into subsets
that share common features,
and then we call this
a family of designs.
And the idea is to start
small, so on the left side,
and then you grow the
system over time right?
But only if needed.
So when you do this, you 1440-
strong design space turns out
to be decomposable into
40 different paths.
Now, which path would
you choose here?
Well you want to be as close
to the Pareto front possible.
So this is an example
of all of a path.
In this path, if we
started on the lower
we would start
with 24 satellites
and then we would actually
move them to a lower altitude.
And add 30 more in
step two, and then you
would gradually grow the
constellation over time.
You see that?
This is actually not
too different from how
GPS was done, right?
The GPS constellation
was deployed in phases,
but it was not market
driven, it was just
sort of phasing the
development for risk reduction,
and spreading off the capital.
The other thing
that's interesting
here is that as you
grow the constellation,
it moves further away.
It moves further
away from the front.
So when it's small, this
particular [INAUDIBLE]
is close to being optimal,
and as you scale it
up it becomes more sub-optimal.
And there's other paths that
have the opposite behavior;
where when small it's
kind of suboptimal,
and as you make it bigger, it
gets closer to the optimality.
Pretty interesting.
So that's step two,
find the paths.
Step three, you now have to
model the actual uncertainty.
And in this case there
are different ways
to model uncertainty.
In this case, what we
used was a GBM model--
geometric Brownian motion.
This is well-known in
physics and applied
to statistics, physics,
this has been applied
to the stock market, right?
And the idea here is
that in this case,
the man behaves like
a particle in a fluid.
Right?
That's kind of moving in
an unpredictable fashion.
So this is the basic
equation for-- this
is a discrete version of
geometric Brownian motion,
you have some trends
nu, nu times delta-t,
so this is the delta and
demand, or the change in demand,
divided by demand, so this is
normalized change in demand,
is nu times delta-t,
so your trend times
delta-t plus sigma times epsilon
times square root of delta-t.
Epsilon is a standard,
normally distributed
random variable between 0
and 1, and epsilon and sigma
is your volatility, essentially.
So here's some
examples, if you start
with an initial
demand of 50,000,
which is what they actually
saw as an initial demand early
on, you have a growth
of about 8% per year.
This is your trend.
Plus in this case,
a volatility of 40%
per year, which seems high
but in this kind of very
new technology, new system, is
actually not that far fetched.
You get three different-- these
are just three examples of how
demand might evolve.
These are just three scenarios.
So demand can go up,
it can go down, and--
GBM is very nice, but one
of the downsides of GBM
is there's infinitely many
scenarios that you can generate
because it's fundamentally--
even though it's
discretized in time, it's not
discretized and in demand.
So a simpler version of this,
a more discrete version,
is a so-called
binomial lattice model.
So the way this
works is again, you
start with some initial
demand here on the left
and then you discretize this
such that moving through time,
you can look at
different scenarios.
Right?
These scenarios could
be-- the best scenario
is things just keep growing.
Right?
Grow, grow, grow.
Here, time, the 15 years,
have been sub-divided
into five three-year periods.
So here's a sample scenario,
demand goes up, goes up,
and then it goes
down twice, and then
it goes up again in the period.
And so this is a
discretized random walk.
And you can choose the numbers,
so the sigma, the volatility,
the amount of the up and down
movement, and the probability,
p, of going up, and then
the probability of 1
minus p of going
down, are chosen such
that they're consistent
with the GBM model.
So this model is the
equivalent of the GBM model,
it's just discretized.
So the beauty of this
is that you can now
simplify this to 32
different scenarios
instead of infinitely many.
And each of those scenarios
is not equally probable.
There is actually probability
weighted scenarios,
depending on what nu and
sigma are that are underlined.
So now we have 40 paths, right?
We have 40 evolution
paths of the system
and we have 32 different
future scenarios.
So what we do now in
the next step, four,
is to put the two
together and calculate
the cost of each path.
Calculate the cost of
each path with respect
to each of the demand
scenarios, look
at the weighted average of all
the possible paths, and the one
thing--
the one tricky
thing about this is
you need to build
in a decision rule.
Such that, if the system--
if demand exceeds
capacity the system,
you're going to expand and
move to the next stage,
you're going to stage
deploy the next phase.
And there's many different ways
of doing this decision rule.
So the simplest one
was chosen here,
and of course costs
are discounted.
So let me explain to
you how this works.
So we start the simulation, so
the first initial deployment.
This is our initial stage one--
right-- for the constellation.
And then we start
operating for two years,
and demand in this
period goes up.
You see the ops cost in this
case goes slightly down,
this is due to the discounting.
This is a discounting effect.
We arrive at the end of
our first three year period
and then the question is here
is our capacity of the system.
What would you do
in this situation?
Let me ask somebody
at MIT, make sure you
guys are still with me.
So what would you do
in this situation?
You're now at the
end of year three.
Anybody?
AUDIENCE: We lost you
for a second halfway
through your statement,
could you repeat?
PROFESSOR: Yes, so you've
done your initial three years,
you've deployed your
initial constellation.
And you now have the
situation shown on this chart.
What's the right decision,
according to the decision rule?
What's the right decision?
AUDIENCE: OK, I'd
keep it the same.
Because--
PROFESSOR: Yes, exactly.
AUDIENCE: --it has not
exceeded demand yet.
But prepare to change--
PROFESSOR: Exactly,
you wait, right?
AUDIENCE: Because you have
to lower your capacity.
PROFESSOR: You keep it the
same, you don't do anything.
You just keep operating.
Exactly, right.
So you have another
three years, right?
During these three years,
demand keeps growing.
And you now, at year six,
arrive at this point here.
So what's the
right decision now?
AUDIENCE: Can I ask a
question about the decision
to stay the same?
PROFESSOR: Would
you say the same?
What's happening
to the demand line?
Veronica, what's happening
AUDIENCE: Can I ask a
quick question first,
about the decision
to stay the same?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I feel like by waiting
until we've exceeded demand
to choose to expand
the constellation,
we're introducing a lag
between demand and capability
that creates an inefficiency
that may actually drive users
away from the system.
And I see this kind of
oscillatory effect, where
you would expand, and
then people would meet,
and then the system
would be insufficient
and then people would move
to a different system.
And you kind of have a yo-yo
around the maximum carrying
capacity.
And that doesn't
seem efficient to me,
so I'm wondering if you
could speak to that.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So what
you're essentially
looking for is what I would
[INAUDIBLE] decision rule.
So you would actually--
so the decision here
is to deploy, right?
You've got to deploy your
second stage because you've
saturated the system.
What you're arguing for
is before this occurs,
you know like at 80%
saturation, that's
when you trigger the
next stage, right?
In order to anticipate
the saturation.
And so, absolutely,
you could do this.
There are many
different decision rules
that you can try when you
design a flexible, deployable,
scalable system.
And that's part of
the decision space.
So in this particular
example, we just
implemented the simplest
possible decision rule,
which was when saturation
has occurred you do deploy
the next stage, but not before.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
PROFESSOR: Is that clear?
AUDIENCE: Yes, thank you.
PROFESSOR: OK, so we deploy
the second stage now,
and you can see there's another
spike here-- right-- of capital
that's needed.
It's not as high as the
first initial stage,
but it is substantial.
So now as we deploy
the next stage,
our capacity went
to the higher limit.
So we're now at
capacity level two.
We're now operating the system.
Demand keeps
growing, that's good.
Now we have year
nine, you can see.
But we haven't yet
saturated our new capacity.
So again, the
optimal decision is--
or I shouldn't say
the optimal decision,
but the decision
according to the rule
is you just wait, right?
You keep operating.
Ah, now from year nine to year
12, demand starts to go down.
Right?
And this happens in
some systems, right?
They are growing and they
peak, and then things go down.
So in this case, we wait.
And then in this scenario
it goes down again.
You see how that works?
So what's nice about
this is you can now--
in this sense, all the 32
scenarios of possible futures,
you can run them against
the 40 different families
of designs or evolution paths.
And out of that you can
find the best path, right?
This is the path, the
path that on average--
I should point out on average--
will satisfy your demand
at minimum lifecycle costs,
given the uncertainty models
that you have composed.
Yes, [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Why did it go down?
AUDIENCE: Like, [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: This here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No, the
capacity stays the same.
You don't go down in capacity.
The reason is-- this
is a good question--
this particular system,
a satellite constellation
is dominated by
fixed costs, right?
So if you wouldn't retire
half your satellite,
because then you would lose
coverage also, potentially.
Because you've moved
them through orbits
that give you the
right coverage,
you just increased
your capacity.
This is different
from a system that
is dominated by variable costs.
Like for example, if you
operate a fleet of taxis
and and for whatever reason,
demand goes way down,
you can go and park
half your taxis
and just not operate them.
You may still have to
pay a lease on them,
but essentially you
can downward that
the capacity of the system.
You can't do that here,
it doesn't make sense.
Right?
So that's the big
difference between systems
that are fundamentally
fixed cost dominated
versus variable cost.
So in this case, we just
don't use it as efficiently
in the last six years.
The answer here is that there's
an optimal path, and that's
shown here, that will, for
a given targeted capacity,
you can compare
essentially this blue path
against the traditional
fixed design.
And in this case, the
traditional architecture--
fixed architecture-- would
cost about $2 billion dollars
to build, both and on
average the red point is
the average lifecycle cost of
the evolvable system, is 1.36.
Right?
Lifecycle cost of the rigid
design versus the expected
lifecycle cost of
the best deployment
strategy or staged deployment
strategy, which is--
essentially the way
that's calculated
is the probability
weighted lifecycle
cost of each of the
scenarios, right?
Against this path.
And the difference between those
two numbers is about a third,
$650 million.
And that is the value
of the real option.
That's the value of designing
the system with scalability,
with flexibility.
OK?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes.
That's true.
So the lifetime--
the question was,
is the life expectancy similar?
Of course-- so the 15 year
life of the whole system
is the same for both.
Of course, in the staged
deployment strategy,
some of the satellites
are going to be younger
at the end of the 15 years.
And so they may have
longer residual life left,
which is actually not included.
That's not even included
in this real option value.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right.
PROFESSOR: That-- that's right.
So you could sort of refine
this model to include a more--
a staged decommissions, right?
Or staged transition to
a next generation system.
So in this case, in this
model, after 15 years--
boom-- you know everything,
you just finish.
No more revenues, you
just decommission.
A hard end, a hard
stop after 15 years.
But you could actually build
transition and decommissioning
models as well.
Good point.
So that's essentially
the case study
that I wanted to show you.
And, you know, you say
that's kind of like in the US
we talk about Monday morning
quarterbacking, you know?
You come in and all the
football games that happened
and the mistakes that
the coaches made,
and I would have done this
or I would have done that.
So yes, you know, this
is sort of like looking
at this problem in
hindsight, but the reality
is that this really has had a
big impact and a big dampening
effect and that the new
generation of systems--
I think-- are built
much more intelligently
with this kind of
evolution in mind.
I will also mention to you that
Iridium is actually the system
that went bankrupt first.
And the reason for
the bankruptcy-- well,
one of the immediate
reasons for the bankruptcy--
is because of the way that
the project was financed.
So about one third of the
funds-- the $5 billion--
one third of the
funds for Iridium
came from equity from Motorola.
So that was their own
money that they lost.
About one third was an IPO,
initial public offering,
you know, shares
sold to the public.
And about one third
was bank loans.
And these bank loans
were relatively expensive
and the banks
expect that they get
paid back at a certain speed,
depending on the market
evolution.
And it's essentially
the inability
to pay for and service
their loans, that
caused the Iridium bankruptcy.
And it turns out that the
loans were about one third
of the total capitalization
of the project.
So what I would argue--
I would argue that if they
had done this more flexible,
staged approach, they
could have saved one
third, which is about
the value of this option
and capitalization, and
just build the system only
with equity and with
the money from the IPO.
And that would have given
them a lot more time,
you know they wouldn't have
had to service those loans
and it would have given
them a lot more time
to wait for the
market to develop,
which it eventually did.
So the whole
financial architecture
was poorly done as well.
It's a whole other--
that's a whole other question.
AUDIENCE: Professor,
quick question?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Are there
situations where [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So the question, I'm
just going to repeat it
for you guys at MIT,
the question was
are there cases where the
flexible approach is not
the best?
And the answer is yes.
So for example, if you're in--
I know that you're studying
the energy market--
if you're in a situation
where you have guarantees,
a guaranteed customer,
so the government
or one of the big
utilities is entering
into a long-term
agreement with you,
that they will buy
the power that you
produce at a certain price
for the next 20 years.
And so you're not subject
to that market volatility,
but you have a long term
agreement, including clauses
that say well if the
government doesn't do this then
they'll compensate
you for any losses,
this is a financial contraction.
If you basically have eliminated
demand uncertainty, because
of the particular
contractual arrangements,
then there's no reason you
shouldn't build the system
for a fixed capacity.
And then you can build something
right on the pareto front,
because that
particular uncertainty
has been eliminated for
policy or contractual reasons.
So, good question.
OK, so we're almost there.
Let me just try to
summarize some--
AUDIENCE: Can I ask you
question on that last slide?
PROFESSOR: Please, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: On the
slide before, 37.
It seemed like the
probability weighting
was for a general capacity.
Like something that could be
adapted over the life cycle
but here we're pinning
down a specific capacity.
So why is it the sum
of probabilities, then?
Haven't, kind of, the
probabilities been
realized, don't you know
exactly what your capacity is
that you're operating at?
PROFESSOR: Yes, so just
to be clear on this.
So the probability,
those p's of i's,
they come from
the lattice model.
They are determined
by the lattice model.
So what you do is for those
32 scenarios of the future,
this is the pi, right?
The i is the index, is the--
for this particular
future scenario,
for each future
scenario, you always
start with a1, which is
your initial configuration
of the constellation.
You always start with a1.
And for each of those
future scenarios,
you then simulate that
future and for those futures,
where the demand doesn't
ever really take off
and materializes,
you never actually
trigger that next
expansion stage.
And it's actually that asymmetry
that gives you the advantage.
And it's essentially
not deploying capacity
when you really don't need it.
And so you do this
for all of this n
scenarios for the future,
and the pi, the probability,
weighting of each
future scenario
comes directly out
of the lattice model.
That's not something that you
have to manually determine.
AUDIENCE: Right, no,
I understand that.
But here, since we've kind of
pinned down a capacity already,
we know what endpoint we're at.
I'm just wondering how the
probabilities come into that,
or is it kind of working
backwards now, of all the paths
that go there on
this specific plot?
PROFESSOR: I see
what you're saying.
OK.
So the last point, the
a1 point, so the a1 point
is driven by-- you need
to make some assumptions
about initial capacity and
then the endpoint, the a4,
is driven by how large
you made the trade space.
So you could make
the trade space,
you could make the design
space even larger, right?
This is a discretized full
factorial design space,
you could make it even larger.
And then a4 would
not be the end form.
This is just sort of
a finite size effect,
given to the size
of the trade space.
AUDIENCE: All right, thanks.
PROFESSOR: All right, so the way
I want to do the summary here
is just go back to the
learning objectives.
You know, I always do this
in every class, you know,
let's close the loop.
What did I promise
you in lecture one
that you would
learn in this class?
And, you know,
each of you, you're
going to have to decide
for yourself, you know,
did I actually learn this?
Did we actually do this?
So this is sort of due diligence
on the learning objectives.
And I have one slide
on each of them.
So the first objective was to--
for you to really
understand the system
engineering standards
and best practices,
as well as more approaches.
Number two is understand the key
steps in the system engineering
process.
Number three was
analyze and understand
the role of humans in the
system as beneficiaries,
designers, operators,
and so forth.
Number four was being
honest and characterizing
the limitations of system
engineering as we practice it
today.
And then objectified
learning and objectifiable
was applying these methods
and tools to a real--
even if not so complex-- cyber
electromechanical system.
So I see one,
essentially, hopefully--
no, we didn't check
the readings but I'm
hoping that you did your
readings, that you really
feel like you understand
the NASA System Engineering
Handbook, which is our
quasi-textbook for this class.
But there's other
standards as well,
such as the
[INAUDIBLE] handbook,
which is actually the
basis for certification.
So several of you--
your [? EPS ?] fellow
mentioned to me
that you're interested
in certification,
so I encourage that.
Most of that is based
on the number two.
I did mention the
ISO standard 15288.
That's probably the best known
standard; ISO is a very--
they're located
right here in Geneva.
ISO is a very important
organization, you know?
I know ISO standards are not the
most exciting things to read,
but they have huge
impact and so 15288
is something that
worldwide-known and across all
industries really.
And then I want to mention
also the European Systems
Engineering Standard.
And Foster Voelker
and I had a discussion
about this earlier today.
This is issued by the
European Space Agency.
And it is a little-- there
are some subtle differences
between ISO approach
and the NASA approach.
And so for those of you on
this side of the Atlantic,
I do encourage you to take
a look at that [? ESES ?]
standard as well.
And then we augmented this with
different papers, and readings,
and so forth.
So I want to do a very quick--
this is our last concert
question for the class.
So here's the link,
[INAUDIBLE] and it's
essentially I want to
get some feedback what
you think about the standard.
All outdated and surpassed
by the digital revolution,
one of you thinks that's true.
90% of you think they're useful
codification and best practice.
14% think they can
be dangerous if you
adhere to them too closely.
About 60% of you think
they're essential reading
for any serious system engineer.
And 10% said that you
would never use them
as a daily reference book.
VOELKER: OK, so that's good.
I think that's-- what
do you think, Voelker,
pretty reasonable outcomes?
OK.
But what is true is
that they're going
to be referenced, in contracts.
You know if-- if you're doing--
you know, it depends, again,
on the industry that you're in.
But you're going
to adhere to some
of these things in contracts,
and if things don't go well,
people will actually check
whether, did you do this step,
did you do that step.
So it does have
real consequences.
PROFESSOR: OK, great.
Thank you very much.
That was that was good.
Step two, you know the
key steps, v model,
I think I'm not going
to explain it again.
You know, hopefully
this is something
that you will not forget.
And just one point
about the v model
is it does not imply that
system engineering is always
sequential.
You know, it's possible
to iterate between steps
and across the whole v as well.
SE3, stakeholders
and value of network.
So this is the role of humans.
We talked about this very
early on, several of you
talked about it during
the oral exam here today.
You know, the hub and spoke
versus the stakeholder value
network.
The method underlying
this is critical, but I do
want to mention, very quickly--
and this is something we
didn't spend a lot of time on--
is human factors.
Right?
How do you design systems so
that humans can effectively
and safely use them?
You know, interfaces,
procedures, and so this
is a couple of slides from
one of my colleagues, Missy
Cummings.
This is actually some--
in a nuclear plant--
Katya, you're going
to like this--
lots of these dials,
and this is actually
a Russian nuclear plant.
So it has it has a
very specific layout.
And so the important
questions in human factors
are, how do you best
display status information?
What tasks do humans do?
What level of automation?
What are the training
requirements?
And these are also very
important questions.
And so you can apply the
human systems engineering
process, very much
analogous to what
we covered in class so far.
So you do mission and scenario
analysis, function allocation.
And then in human factors, you
talk more about task analysis.
But essentially, eventually,
leads to system design.
Like what are the
buttons that you
push, what does the layout
look like, or the user
interface, and so forth.
So, you know, I'm not I'm
not presenting human factors
as a separate topic, but the
human factors requirements
should be built in
right from the start.
And essentially the
functional allocation
is sort of a key question here.
How much is done by automation,
how much is done by humans,
and how do you split
between the two?
And one of the most important
things to consider here
is this human performance curve.
And we know this
pretty well now,
that when humans are
extremely highly loaded--
you know, when you
have a huge workload--
your performance goes down.
But interestingly, if
you're under challenge
your performance
goes down as well.
And you know, so
for example, people
who are in power stations
or mission control
centers where nothing is
happening for days and weeks,
you know their
attention goes down,
and they don't perform
at a very high level.
Humans perform best at
a moderate workload,
and this is well-known.
And it should influence
how you define
the human interface and
the split among automation
and humans.
SE4, system complexity.
Last time I will
mention the magic number
seven, plus or minus two.
The real limitations come in
and when we operate at levels,
you know, three,
four, five, and six.
And the main reason for this
is because now a single human
cannot understand,
cannot remember,
cannot deal with all
the detailed components.
And you need to split
the work among teams,
among organizations, and
creates extra interfaces
and complexities.
OK?
And just to show you, Iridium,
we talked about Iridium.
This is a very recent news
story this is from October 29th.
The new Iridium Next has
again been pushed back
by four months.
This gentleman here is the CEO
of Iridium, chief executive
for Iridium Next, Mr. Desh.
And he's talking here about
a particular [INAUDIBLE]
and then Viasat is one
of the contractors.
There's a particular component
that's been giving trouble,
and that's sort of in level
three or four in the hierarchy,
and that's essentially
delaying the whole system.
So there's an example of how the
large complexity of the system
is causing issues.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: But they're
actually a supplier
to [INAUDIBLE] through
the whole chain, right?
Oh you're saying there's more
going on than meets the eye.
Yeah, who knows?
Who knows?
OK, and then finally here I
want to mention application
to a case study.
You know, we used the
CanSat 2016 competition
as a quote, unquote
safe case study.
And I have to say I'm
really pleased with how
this worked out.
You had the 47
requirements as a starter,
you approved, them
you group them,
and my comments about the
PDR that we had a week ago
are all teams passed
successfully, the PDR.
You know, if this
was a real PDR,
we would have issued a couple
of [? ridds, ?] I think.
There was some-- a couple
of teams were over budget,
or needed to work out their
aerodynamics in more detail.
But by and large I thought this
was an excellent application
of system engineering concepts.
Went beyond my expectations.
Several of you
mentioned the importance
of concept generation,
you know hybrid use
of structured and unstructured
creativity techniques.
I know at least one team
applied to actually go
to the competition.
And this shows you
a couple examples.
So we have one team
here at the EPSL
using a bio-inspired design.
This is an actual seed airfoil
that actually occurs in nature.
And then here's an example from
MIT, the Rogallo Wing Team 7.
So, I'm sorry I didn't
mention all the teams here,
but it was really great to
see the application of this
in the CanSat competition case.
So the last thing I want to
do-- and I only have one minute
left, actually I'm already
slightly over time--
but I just want to give
you some career and study
recommendations.
So first of all, you know, I
want to make sure that you--
and I said this in
the first lecture--
there's a lot more to the
system engineering and systems
research than we were able
to cover in this class.
So this class is really what I
call a door opener to the world
of system engineering.
If you want to go deeper,
there are deeper subjects.
You know, model based system
engineering is the big trend.
System safety.
And then in the
spring I'm teaching
a class called
Multi-Disciplinary System
Optimization.
And there is actually a
WebEx access to it as well.
So it's not going to
be officially offered
as a [INAUDIBLE] class, but if
individual students here are
interested, please contact me.
Self-study, you know the
System Engineering Journal,
there's IEEE journals,
there's also--
you know, for some of you this
is maybe a little too soon--
but there's professional
degrees in system engineering.
For example at MIT we have
the SDN program, System Design
and Management.
The average age of the
students in that program is 33,
but it is--
they're sort of coming back
to get their masters in system
design and management.
And there's quite a bit
of SLOAN content as well.
So finance, you know,
understanding the financial--
how to build a business
case around systems as well.
Professional experience.
You know, getting experience
in actual projects.
Like at MIT, for example Rexus.
You know, you've got the
Clean Space One project,
we heard about [? Optaneous ?]
One, Solar Impulse,
there are a lot
of opportunities.
Or-- we also had
a couple of people
here mention that you're
starting your own company,
your own venture.
And you know, when
you're doing, that you
have to be the system engineer.
You have to understand all
of these things, interfaces,
suppliers, requirements,
markets, all
that has to be integrated.
Finally, you did
hear about INCOSE.
We had a quick dial-in
with at an earlier session.
So if you're interested,
you can join either
as a student or a
professional member.
And also certification.
This class was not
[INAUDIBLE] for that,
but if you're interested
in this site, [INAUDIBLE]
number of years of experience
at the [? CCF ?] level.
And then finally,
please keep in touch.
And last but not
least, I want to thank
all of you, the students at MIT,
at EPFL, our TAs, [INAUDIBLE]
here at EPFL, Johana at
MIT, the technical staff
has been helping run the
technology, Voelker, thank you.
And-- and that's it.
So I want to thank all of you.
Next week we do have
a voluntary seminar
on sort of future
trends in manufacturing,
but again, it's not mandatory.
It's going to be in the
same place, but like I said,
it's not part of
the official class.
So with that, sorry for running
a little bit over time but
it's been a joy to
teach this class
in this kind of new format.